all right guys we're gonna get into the
lecture today which is chess and the
Romantic era every era is the Romantic
era though if you try hard enough now
back then we had some real you know
dynamic chess players let's be honest I
mean chess was a lot different back in
the day
sacrifices were more acceptable nowadays
you can't sacrifice a piece because
somebody's going to pull out their cell
phone and tell you that it's a mistake
with their chess engine but you know I
think if you look at some of those old
great games that are not only
instructive but entertaining to look at
like Paul Morphy or you know any of
these great attacking players but Mike
he'll tell you look at their games and
you might be able to refute or claim to
beat them by using an engine because
half of their moves and maybe our
mistakes but it's not so much about the
computer evaluation it's more the
pressure that attacking chess is able to
put on your opponent and again nowadays
you're able to look at you know some of
those old games and just say you know
what nonsense are these guys doing but
when you're in a practical game and the
guys sitting right in front of you
sacrificing these pieces attacking your
King it's not so easy to defend and of
course I'm I'm very well aware of some
of the very famous players from from
these these old you know let's say the
Romantic era but tonight I wanted to
look at a few players who hopefully
you've never heard of in fact if you
have heard of them I would like to
personally award you a cookie chocolate
chip variety and we have a game here
between Carl camp and Phillip Manor all
right anyone know who they are no
cookies good so yeah Carl camp is I'm
not going to pretend to know him a first
name basis but he played along with his
partner it takes two to tango
Philip mate never played one of the
craziest games that ended in a draw a
game that I think is really worth
looking at because not just with the
computer but with our minds were able to
consider alternate variations that could
have happened in this game and I'd be
curious what your evaluation is as to
how this game played out and whether
either side has had a chance to actually
play for a win because this is one of
the most insane draws that I've ever
seen and I'm excited to show you so
we'll take a look at this game here
started a 45 ok
these guys know what they're doing
Knight c3 so we're playing the Vienna
and after Bishop c5 we already see that
white decides to do something which is
absolutely not to normal however not a
very strange move at all I mean
night-night a4 is probably not the best
move because at the very least if black
moves his bishop back here the Knights
offside we know that the knight he's
gonna have to return at some point and
black basically got the free move Bishop
d7 instead of it sitting with my fate so
may 4 is absolutely not
you know a critical move it's not the
best move but I bet when he played a
knight a 4 he didn't expect Bishop takes
F to the already black just gives away a
piece normally if I mean if he told me
that that someone was going to be down a
piece on move three or four I would
assume they're around 1100 rated or
lower but this this guy Philip actually
played Bishop f2 with with complete
intention of justifying it with Queen to
h4 and the idea being if g3 to take on
e4 and say that you know by forking the
rook or the night that this sacrifice is
actually justified because not only did
I get the f2 pawn and the e4 pawn but
I'm gonna reclaim my piece and say that
I'm gonna be at least one or two pawns
up at the end of this so that's the idea
with g3 if king e - it's also a little
more straightforward because this is now
a check have to move
we take tonight so we can actually you
know pretty easily see why Queen age
four makes a lot of sense but the real
question is the move played in the game
King III how do we justify this because
now it's it's not so clear where we're
getting our knight back and we might
have to be comfortable in a position
like this playing down a piece and after
Queen f4 check again if the King goes
back to e two we just looked at that
line Queen takes e4 check winning that
night on a4 king d3 so at this point I
mean in Canada we call this going for a
jog so that's what the white King is
doing here after king d3 black played e5
and he's basically holding nothing back
he's saying that although I'm down a
piece a full piece I have every
intention to try to bring my pieces out
with tempo trying to pressure this white
King and not give him time to retreat
into the safety of his own pawns his own
pieces so for example one you know
natural sort of ideas like well I'll
play let me play c3 and and sort of get
my King back into safety the whole point
of d5 said after Queen e4 it's just
check me so I'm playing as black here
I'm playing the type of moves that might
not be the best moves but they're the
moves that are gonna prevent you from
playing the natural defensive resources
that you're counting on I think everyone
who has their king in the middle of the
board wants to bring their King back and
d5 is kind of a resourceful move because
if I take it of course this Knight let's
not forget it's just hanging on a fourth
so if white is gonna have his King in
the middle he has to be quite careful
not to ever give back the material
because as soon as the material is equal
white is gonna be worse because his King
is out there first role so he's got to
do his best to hang on to the material
and that's what he does he plays King c3
I mean you're already out may as well
keep going
King c3 Queen takes c4 why not free pawn
and once again we renew the threat of
Queen takes a four here I mean hey let's
keep going King b3 why not King is an
attacking piece
and after king b3 we we finally see that
okay
maybe black doesn't have you know a
forced way to to checkmate or to win
that night back maybe the night will
return to c3 next move with tempo this
bishop is actually a hero because it's
protecting the c4 squared
without that Bishop there'd be big
trouble it's also stopping black from
playing b5 because if Bishop takes pawn
so a bishop on f1 don't forget very
important so black played Knight a six I
mean he could play a number of moves
here knight c6 Bishop d7 they all look
good he decided to play Knight a sex and
what we see next is one of those moves
which is exactly what I was talking
about when you have your king out in the
open you want to play a move to tuck
your king away
I mean it's normal almost everyone would
feel inclined to play either C 3 or a 3
or very least you'd consider it because
no one feels comfortable with the King
in front of the pawns I mean it's almost
no chess positions where your defensive
wall of pawns is sitting behind your
King I think back in the old days
sometimes when you're going into battle
the King leads the charge but that's not
usually how it works in chess so white
played them of a 3 to me it's very
normal
while I cannot play the move King a to
straightaway without losing this Knight
it does set me up to sort of harass his
queen with my pieces and pawns and as
soon as that Queen let's say moves off
the fourth-ranked from attacking my
knight
then I tucked my king away and I start
to regroup and and say ok well at the
end of the day I'm up a piece here so
that should be winning and black it
really wasn't a fan of it he played
Queen takes a 4
and he said well you know if you're
gonna go along the third-ranked like
that why don't you try the fourth-ranked
see how you like it
King takes a 495 and you notice how this
Knight takes away the retreat square
it's trying to keep the King going up
the board white decided to play King
before he could play king b5 but the
point is here then no matter what white
does he can't go backwards he would love
to go backwards 83 was played to
actually hide the King on a 2 that's no
longer possible here so Black Knight c5
check and I should probably point out
that you know I'm quite sure Thank You
Ben Simon it's quite clear that you know
most engines would probably be saying
something around plus 20 right now
because at the end of the day I'm down a
bishop I'm down a queen what did I get I
think I got two pawns and a knight I
mean that's that's kind of an
embarrassing barter agreement but the
only reason that black is is really
still in the game is because White's
King doesn't have a safe way back so
even though I am running out of pieces
as black if white keeps going forward
practically for a human that's very
uncomfortable to deal with the fact that
your king is never safe and that's
almost the number one priority when when
we're playing is make sure the King is
safe and then work with your pieces to
create an attack here blacks creating
the attack and we're the one that's
scrambling to to find defensive moves so
King b4 was played black decided play a5
check I mean he really has no regard for
pieces at this point he's giving up his
Queen he's giving up his bishop he's now
giving up his knight all this to create
this well maybe it's an illusion but
create this idea that the further you go
up the board doesn't matter how many my
pieces you take I mean the King just
doesn't belong there on move 11 it was
really funny to me is if we sort of
count the moves
we're on move 11 now if we look move 11
move 10 move 9 I mean almost all the
previous moves by white where King moves
which is kind of insane you're you're
not really supposed to touch the King
that many times in fact your husband's
touch the King at all unless you're
castling so maybe we've been breaking
some cardinal rules here but I mean if
someone accuses me as white and move my
King too much I would look at him and be
like well come on man
the guy's sacked his Queen is Bishop and
he's a knight I mean what I'm supposed
to do I can't not take this stuff so he
takes it why not I haven't tried the
fifth rank yet I don't know how safe it
is out there King takes e5 now once you
all just stop and just appreciate this
position right now where I moved 12 and
there's a king on the fifth ring it
doesn't matter if it's a white or a
black King that's incredible but it's a
little more unbelievable that it's a
white King on the fifth ring that's
animate that technically that's enemy
territory you know you're not supposed
to be behind enemy lines like that in
fact the white king is closer to the
black King than his own home that's a
bit crazy they can almost have a Skype
call by now 97 why 97 well I've actually
got a great little sort of frontier of
pawns that I'm able to control all the
squares that the king would like to
retreat to but if I let any of these
poems go all of a sudden that King
starts to go backwards and it's I think
it's been pretty clear so far that I
mean black is willing to give almost
anything to force the King up the board
not back so he plays the move in 97 with
the idea hey I'm gonna defend this pawn
and the King I mean as soon as I'm able
to give it a few checks it's gonna have
to go up and up the board and eventually
hopefully run into a meeting net so
white actually quite impressively comes
up with a nice move here and I say
impressively even though whites up maybe
more material than I personally ever
been up in a chess game
the reason I say impressively is because
I think it's very close to checkmate
it's it's very uncomfortable as white
there's no way back and you almost feel
like well you've got all this extra
material it's so disconnected from your
King that it might not be useful at all
we might get a position where we don't
even get to use you know these extra
Queen's bishops Knights that we have so
white actually plays the move Bishop b5
and because it's a check well I'm
actually inclined to say that it's it's
quite quite a good move
if we don't play Bishop b5 I mean I
challenge you to suggest another move
but black has as very very specific
intentions what am i threatening in this
position if let's say white made a move
that was completely irrelevant like I
mean h3 yeah what do you think that hub
of the green now let's say that white
makes a random like that what does black
threatening that's what I want to know
like where's the beautiful checkmate
alright help them out beside
not allowed not allowed sure
I'm Bishop t7s meet that's right
Bishop d7s me so actually 97 if we play
random move here I mean it's not like
blacks just trying to box me up he's
actually gonna win the whole game v6
King b5 but it'd be 7 I mean it's
embarrassing but it's over and the move
Bishop b5 check has the idea that if
black plays c6 all of a sudden my king
although it's up the board does have a
few more options to escape so it's not
in blacks interest to play the move c6 I
think we need to play Bishop d7 or King
d8 the reason Bishop d7 is not the most
appetizing is because we previously
needed that Bishop to deliver the mate
so black plays the move King d8 he's
saying actually your own Bishop is
trapping your King because you'd like to
maybe use that Square to escape with
your King now you can't even do that so
white plays this move if I was you know
giving the the annotations for this game
I would give a couple exclamation marks
to Bishop c6 because that might just be
the move that saves his life here if b6
now we can see the difference so that
Bishop covers this diagonal there's no
check on d7 and Bishop a6 is a bit less
effective because now we get to do what
black never wanted to happen which is
the king going backwards
any time we start to make steps
backwards always in White's favor or I
would say generally in White's favor
so after Bishop c6 let's say b6 king b5
black says okay I'll play Knight takes
c6 getting rid of the bishop I mean if
you move the King back now I'm curious
what
black would do after King a4 because
that should always be your question when
you're trying to deliver checkmate to
someone who king is on the fifth rank
you got to ask yourself what if he
starts running away he doesn't need to
take this name because White's up so
much material here not just to mention
the Queen
but much more than that so what if King
a for how did we actually 94 and why is
94 so strong it's not even check B 5
will be a check made Bishop d7 will be a
checkmate but really 94 covers the
escape square and a lot of times in
chess what you'll find is one of the
strongest moves to make in a position
instead of checking your opponent and
having them run away from your checks is
to take away the square they're gonna
run two and prepare to check the next
move
so what you keep them in a box to keep
them contained so 94 is a fantastic move
it covers b3 and we notice that white is
actually no way to move backwards here
and also no way to stop one of the many
checkmates that is coming up next
so 94 would be game over so I mean when
in Rome
King takes c6 White's King made it to
the sixth rank in this game and the only
thing that's wrong about blacks position
is he almost doesn't have any pieces
left that's the issue and I mean I think
that's the worst part is that he's
running out of pieces if you had just
one night one extra piece this might be
a lot easier he plays the move Bishop b7
now why didn't you play Bishop d7
because White was about to do what we
were talking about which is move
backwards and take this pawn and sort of
facilitate all these exit strategies
King takes pawn king e4 King c4 many
ways to get out so at this point I don't
think black is gonna be too offended
giving away a bishop when he's already
given away Queen two knights and another
bishop so I think he's fine with that if
he plays this insane move Bishop d7 well
let someone tell me what happens if I
take that
ting d7
inje for check-in can be six
and now unfortunately for white all
those Queen is developed with Czech I
mean no nobody else is helping here and
this rook b8 move is quite unstoppable
check me
I mean maybe white was trying to get
some points for for a touchdown with the
king but if you're only gonna make it to
the seventh ring I don't think there's
any points awarded for that King takes
b7 doesn't work and white saw this
because King d7 King desex
and surprisingly that's just check me it
on the board black only has two rooks
and a king and all of them work together
to deliver that meet so in this position
white saw that and said well okay
clearly I have to go here it's a black
played Bishop a6 check and why didn't
white play King a4 because again the
first thing you calculate all the time
is why doesn't white go backwards he's
got enough material he doesn't need to
keep taking things if he can to get that
King to safety black is his dad lost so
what do we play after King a4 sorry b5
Bishop c4 and why Bishop c4 because
we're gonna do the exact same thing that
I just talked about which is not
shacking your opponent but taking away
the square that he's gonna run to if you
think about playing tag in the
schoolyard you're not supposed to just
run at the person try to tag them so
they're gonna DQ oh they're gonna run
away so if you're two people trying to
corner one person you don't both run at
them you know you may be spread out try
to take the the space way around them
that they're gonna run to you slowly
corner them in and then it's easy as you
can tell I'm a tag expert
Bishop c4 just comes from my hey days of
tag take away the square that the king
is gonna run to it's got nowhere left to
go and then you can see our next move
unstoppable I can close my eyes and play
it b5 that's checkmate
no matter what you do game over so white
realized he couldn't play King a4 so
well that makes things simple there's
only one move to play it's came back to
c6 and as black remember we had no way
of dealing with the King taking on d5
except it should be seven and in one of
the most sort of miraculous displays of
repetition in chess the game was
actually drawn like this so black is
down if we do a head count here what a
knight and a queen okay not that bad not
that bad and only a knight in a queen
but to be able to find like a perpetual
check when you're down at night in a
queen especially you know from a insane
game like this and I mean Black was
sacrificing pretty much every time it
was legal it just gave away Queen give
aways Knight Bishop everything even at
the end he sacrificed his bishop the
white can't take it
and so this game is kind of the perfect
example of to me one of the the craziest
most sacrificial games were nobody one
because white white was game - I mean it
doesn't just take bravery from black to
sacrifice every piece that he did it
take bravery from white to put your king
on c6 I mean nowadays I think if anyone
played a game like this and my King
ended up that far up the board I would
assume that my opponent just prepared
one of the most brilliant games I've
ever seen
back then you probably never knew it was
like 50/50 chance every move either for
my opponent is just the worst player
ever and he's blundering his queen or
he's a genius and I'm about to get
checkmate it either way I mean it was
probably interesting to find out but
nowadays I mean if I see a strong player
offering me this man
pieces I'm gonna assume that my game is
gonna end up in a tactic book not for a
good reason so that's why I mean I'm so
fascinated by some of these older games
that were able to look at and and and
really appreciate that nobody can play
chess like this anymore
not only would a complete computer tell
you to take a hike if you ever tried to
sacrifice your queen like this like I
said during this game you know I haven't
done it because just feels disingenuous
but I'm sure if you flick on the
computer it would just tell you to to
get out of here I mean you know plus 10
or maybe checkmate by forest who knows
but you really can't play games like
this anymore because like I said if
someone was sacrificing all these pieces
that I'm assuming that it would just be
something they had prepared nobody would
really just sack a queen the way that
these guys did because of their
intuition nowadays that's just not a
risk people people take you either sack
your queen because he prepared it or you
know it's good or you just don't do that
you just don't do it so I was impressed
not only by like I said by black but
also by white both players were clearly
here to play a fun game and the game
started by just something so innocent
g45 Bishop out to c5 after Knight c3 and
white plays Knight a4 and there's a
number of very reasonable moves here but
black just kind of goes insane plays
Bishop f2 and it created what I think is
one of the most exciting games that
nobody won because we we can now
nowadays have draws that we can
appreciate you can say wow that's a well
played draw that was fighting both
players could won but I don't think that
any draw I've seen recently compares to
to this one so this is one of my
favorite favorite games that actually
did end in a draw by repetition you can
see in the final position here black was
sacrificing everything on the way
but unfortunately at the very end you
just didn't have enough pieces and so we
had a repetition so I thought this game
was a lot of fun when I when I first saw
it and again to end in a draw is just
kind of miraculous I have another game
that I want to take a look at but of
course there weren't many games let's
say in the Romantic era that were played
as crazy as some of those Paul Morphy
games you know some of those really
crazy attacking games almost none of
them were played in that style and
didn't end in and check me I mean when
Paul Murphy was not being brilliant he
was losing I mean he would sacrifice and
he would have amazing games those are
the ones that everyone remembers let's
not forget he also lost a few as well
and I'm sure he made some sacrifices
that were not quite so sound but this is
a game where maybe these sacrifices
weren't sound but you know it's pretty
impressive to see it from two people who
honestly are relatively unknown as I
said earlier I'd be pretty surprised if
if anyone actually knew who these guys
were so this is a game that I really
enjoyed I wanted to take a look at
another one
that I had had prepared here this was
actually relatively short we discussed
the idea of the term miniature it means
a game that finishes and generally under
20 moves this actually qualifies because
they agreed to a draw after Bishop d7 so
me playing these extra moves was just
showing the repetition but really if the
draw was agreed here so in 18 moves
black managed to sacrifice like 20
points in material and draw a repetition
which is kind of kind of incredible so I
enjoyed this game I thought it's quite
fun another game that I wanted to take a
look at was again between two players I
would be impressed if anyone knows does
anyone know these guys
Henry Seymour Conway not Seymour Hoffman
and Thomas Boulder I mean who are these
guys did he even play chess I thought it
was really interesting when I was
getting ready for this lecture to try to
find games from people that I'd
personally never even heard of so I
recently got to know these guys and
their games and you're not gonna find
too many of them because I mean there's
just simply not not gonna be in every
every database guys like Paul Morphy and
McHale towel and Anderson are stealing
the the spotlight so I wanted to take a
moment and appreciate some of the the
cooler games from people who are
relatively unknown that's right hmm let
me just say is probably before you were
born
1788 is the answer but I'm unimpressed
I'm impressed if you could possibly
reference that but now if anyone ever
asks you about your old buddy Henry
Seymour Conway you'd be pleased to say
that you know him quite well you know
about his famous game that he played
against Thomas Thomas the Tank Engine
845 it's funny all these games always
start so innocent I mean the last game
is e45 Knight c3 Bishop c5 and then just
fireworks for the rest of the game okay
II 45 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 d3 okay
rather rather normal black plays c6 I
mean clearly he has the intention to
play d5 this is 1788 by the way the last
game we looked at was almost 100 years
later so this is this is by no means
this is by no means very simple okay c6
Queen e2 can't be too judgmental here I
mean this was 1788 the year of my
favorite scotch
d6f for you know i I got a I got a
respect moves like F for I really do
anyone who's willing to to play like
some sort of delayed Kings gambit is is
definitely definitely in my good books
so after at four you can tell that
things are probably gonna get a little
spicy here these are these are the type
of games as you can see this was a
casual game casual game London 1788 now
compare that to these days I mean
nowadays we're having professional chess
games 2019 World Championship and I'm
here showing you a casual game maybe it
was played in a pub or something in 1788
so you can tell that we're probably
about to have some fun
he takes f4 Bishop f4 Queen b6 black
unleashes the coveted 1788 bar crawl
double attack a lethal a lethal attack
here attacking the knight on g1 in the
pawn on b2 now any logical person would
first of all try to defend both of them
it's what you do in a double attack you
frantically try to defend both of the
attacked pieces at once okay if you
can't do that then the next logical
course of action is try to defend one of
them let's say the more valuable of the
two in this case if I have a knight
hanging in a pawn hanging well generally
I'm going to choose the knight but in
1788
they didn't defend either of them you
play Queen f3 just like what the hell is
this guy up to he's not defending his
knight he's not defending his pawn and
when I take that pawn keep in mind you
know I'm continuing my journey I'm
taking that rook on anyone so really I
mean a lot of whites army is currently
hanging now if I had to choose between a
knight and a pawn which actually
guarantees me that rook I'm probably
gonna take the pawn and so he does and
white says okay Bishop takes f7 maybe he
felt really good maybe there was a nice
lady in the bar he was trying to impress
at the time but after black plays King D
7 he will he was probably embarrassed
because I
think he was counting on maybe black
taking this bishop and then I think he
was gonna show off a Bishop e5 check
lose your queen game over
wasn't to be king d7 okay now after King
d7 your rook really is hanging in the
corner white plays ninety two because
there's really nothing you can do to
save that rook and okay I mean blacks
gonna take it
King d2 once again I do not recommend
turning on the engine while looking at
some of these games as it will look like
you know someone's very very active
heart rate Bishop to b4 Knight c3 and I
mean what is white up to yet you lost
one rook it's like you got addicted or
something now he's losing the other one
and the reason that he did that was
because you know I think if you lose a
Brooke in the corner like that you sort
of want to justify it you want to
pretend like this maybe was part of a
grand plan so he plays King to d2
probably he would have castled if it was
legal but somehow the way his position
is right now all he did was he got a
pawn on f7 and that's it he didn't get
anything more he lost the full rook for
it now he lost another one so actually
if we tally up the material here it's
just too full rooks
for black that's it two extra rooks now
that's kind of it that's kind of insane
after Queen G for King c7 Queen takes g7
okay what white saw that tactic that
blocked it and now he's just trying to
copy it and he's trying to take the rook
on h8 the thing is when you're up so
much material the way that black is
final out to ropes it's like you know
okay and give back to the community you
can have one of them 97 doesn't even
take it now why doesn't he take it
because he's probably making the
practical decision here that if I'm down
to Brooks and I take one you know I'm
not I'm not coming back in this game I'm
still dead lost so he took his chances
and said okay I'm gonna play Queen g3
and pressure this pawn right here
and just sort of wing it I'm gonna throw
all my pieces at the king
I've got no ropes left I've already lost
a knight this is just gonna be my
last-ditch effort the last attacking
game that I could play b6 seems like a
very good move black wants to make room
for his king I mean it seems normal
Knight d5 what the hell is he doing he's
giving away another piece I mean at some
point you have to be careful you can't
deliver a checkmate if you don't have
enough pieces left and so well probably
White was actually he played maybe
Knight d5 and then he probably stopped
and just made sure you count his pieces
make sure you had enough left to
actually deliver that meat but I think
his opponent probably got a little
overzealous here he probably thought
well I mean this guy's giving me
everything I'm just gonna keep taking it
now in my opinion he probably should
have should have chilled out a little
bit and maybe not kept taking because
remember the guy the guy has already
taken so many of whites pieces he
doesn't need to take more if he doesn't
have to so this move C takes b5 actually
in dangers the king and we can see after
Bishop takes d6 King b7 Bishop d5 that's
the whole reason that he made this
Knight move he wanted to open up that
diagonal King a6 and now I want to say
maybe this is the move he missed but I
have a feeling that he was just a little
preoccupied with taking all of White's
pieces that he wasn't focused on the
fact that he may actually lose the game
white played d4 white unleash the idea
of Queen a3 which would be a checkmate
and black now I mean it's very
impressive you know two knights Bishop
couple rooks got a queen over there in
each one let's not forget but they're
not doing anything I mean none of them
can check the White King none of them
can protect their own King so we get
this sort of awkward position where it
seems like black is up so much material
but you know there's some things that
money can't buy
King safety you can't buy that he can't
offer white enough material to have his
King safe here is just nothing he can do
he moved the Knights you move the the I
mean White's checkmating in one here
there's no time before the only move
that really stops Queen a3 okay so what
Bishop takes remember that this Bishop
here is doing something that we talked
about earlier in the class which is it's
it's taking away a square that the King
can run to and it's a lot more valuable
than if the bishop was checking the King
was taking away that square it could run
to is gonna keep that King boxed in on
a6 and that's the beginning of creating
a mating net that's how you win games
you don't just check the King until he
runs out I mean I can't say enough how
many times I watch beginners with Queen
and King against King and there's
checking the King 400 moves you're not
gonna check me it that way you're gonna
have to make a move that's not check in
order to win the game so the bishop on
d5 is fantastic is keeping that King
locked in on a6 okay King b5 he's going
out in the open but at this point he's
just walking into the final blow of the
game
c4 giving away yet another piece and at
this point I have a feeling that he was
just giving away pieces so it looked a
little better when he finally did
checkmate him he can say that he
sacrificed more material probably looks
a little better in the final position
it's actually two rooks and two knights
for nothing but blacks blacks made it
the game's over
sadly there isn't really like some sort
of piece count at the end of the game
there's there's no like aggregate or
anything like that it's just checkmate
you lose so after Queen b5 I mean of
course black black is just
Kayode here but what really happened
this game was black got a little greedy
taking taking pieces now taking these
rooks makes a lot of sense
you know if White's just gonna hang
material you're gonna take it but I
think what blacks big error was was
right here under Knight d5 this is a
little bit greedy to take the knight
which seemingly exposes your your king
unnecessarily and I say exposing your
king although the king is pretty much
already taking a jog but there's no need
to expose it more you're already up
enough material to win the game and I
think that's a good principle to follow
when you're playing your own chess games
is I mean if you have enough material
that you can already say you're safely
winning and your opponent offers you
more material in order to complicate the
game it's often the correct decision is
to simply decline decline this extra
material so let's say here we want to do
what
King da well King d8 I definitely
wouldn't do because then I'm actually
putting my King in a box again
so King d8 then I'm gonna feel the
pressure of this night covering this
square is Bishop covering this square
and slowly it feels like you're in one
of those one of those rooms where you
know if they put the bad guy in those
movies with the spikes and it slowly
closes yeah it's like one of those so
that's what d8 is like it's not very
nice
yeah b8 is a little bit more friendly
because at least if Bishop takes then I
could play King b7 and actually white is
taking the square that his own Knight
would love to jump to so maybe I could
stay alive here now don't get me wrong I
think black is already maybe in some
trouble just visually because we're
running out of squares but obviously
these seem to put up a little more of a
fight than totally exposing ourselves
and walking and of course what we saw is
just just to check me so as you can
probably tell you know the theme of
today's sort of romantic era games has
been has been King walks I mean the King
is just taking a stroll in almost all
these games and again like I said in the
last example
you almost look at this and it's like
how can you fault black I mean the King
is taking a stroll because he he had to
he was forced to by his his crazy
opponent who kept sacrificing things so
I mean I think that's what happened just
just back when these games were were
being played is that there was a whole
different mindset and it was almost like
if you had the initiative if you were
attacking then he were winning that's
almost what you feel like when you go
over these old games is that some of
these these could be grandmasters could
be just casual game in London England in
1788
doesn't matter but White was the one who
seemingly had the aggression the whole
game and he ended up winning now if you
looked at this with a computer I'm sure
it would it would shut you up
immediately very early on and and say
black is completely winning but that's
what I miss let's say about
you know chess is that whenever I
started playing there was already a
pretty clearly defined role with theory
and a lot of things were predetermined
we didn't really have the freedom to
play the games that that you see here
which sadly look like a lot of fun
because I would either appreciate taking
all my opponent's pieces and losing or
giving up all of my pieces and winning I
mean both of those sound like very
attractive options so this is what I
miss
nowadays when I lose all my pieces I
just lose sex it's kind of yeah it just
doesn't work the same way you know
players are too well prepared
there's not many openings or theoretical
examples where I can just toss things
toss things out there and not expect to
lose the game immediately so I have one
last game has anyone ever heard of
either of these players alexander
hoffman and alexander petrov this was a
famous game in 1844 where the loser
would have to change his first name
that's not true so this was played in
Warsaw in Poland 1844 we've looked at a
game late in the 1800s we looked at the
game from the 1700s so I got to find the
middle ground and you know really see
where the theory the cutting-edge theory
was really developing so once again he
45 as I said every game that was rather
interesting to watch back then started
out as a game that was rather
uninteresting to watch me 45 93 96 it's
almost like these guys knew what they
were doing Bishop c4 Bishop c5 c3 Knight
f6 and thank goodness we finally get
some action and I think that was really
how these most of these games worked is
nowadays when we when you study theory
we could go 20 moves deep I mean
grandmasters sometimes play a whole game
where
they and their opponent both have looked
at the moves that appear on the board at
home on their computer so they're ready
know the whole game and I think that
that's just extended over time that
slowly you know we've we've developed we
have the the internet we have chess
engines algorithms and it's just easier
to remember and learn and absorb theory
back then Theory probably ended right
here move three and that probably took
like months to remember it's like okay
these are the best moves so I think
that's why the games were so interesting
back then is that nowadays games are
only interesting once people start to
forget their theory when you watch a
theoretical game it's like oh they just
had a tie they just drew the game in
like 25 moves I didn't even see what
happened well that was all theory they
already knew it but it would be
interesting to watch that game if it got
out of theory and they finally had to
think for themselves so the nice thing
about these games is I know that after
about three moves they're thinking for
themselves that's why we see people down
two ropes by ten moves white played d4
okay invites the movie takes d4 white
continued with E 5 and next move he
could very well play C takes d4 but he
had other ideas after 94 people had
Bishop d5 now this Knight well barring
the move f5 the 90 is actually trapped
doesn't have anywhere to go so it's
reasonable to assume that black might
play the move f5 but it's also
reasonable to assume that it's 1844 and
so he's obviously gonna play Knight
takes f2 when there's a sacrifice to be
had I mean you could almost play
predicted move very effectively by just
looking at the date that these games
were played Knight takes F - King takes
F - of course after D takes c3 again we
might assume that ok you know the King's
under attack we can all see that
discovered check you know it's logical
maybe the King to go back but we're in
1844 so he's gonna go up the board I
mean that's is just par for the course
and I feel like that was almost maybe
maybe whispered over the board maybe
he's a hovering King f1 its opponents
eighteen forty four minutes go up the
board
sorry I forgot King g3
now of course King g3 is gonna produce a
much more interesting game than King f1
King f1 would just be winning this is no
fun in that
King g3 who knows what's gonna happen
pawn takes Bishop takes now if we sort
of tally things up here we could say
that that's actually one two three extra
pawns for black so it's three pawns for
the piece that's not bad that's that's
actually very reasonable compensation
black decides to play the move Knight
isse Evan and white you know again kind
of really asking for it here
now there's a lot of other ways to to
play this position but to move Knight g5
you know it places the knight on a
square where the Queen is just attacking
it but by this x-ray so a very logical
sort of continuation it's like well what
happens with Knight takes Bishop Queen
takes Bishop and just Queen takes Knight
I mean that's a simple tactic I think
they had developed the term tactic in
1844 so you know what is he supposed to
do well actually I think he was showing
off here because Knight takes d5
he played Knight takes f7 and it's like
wait a minute this guy might be a genius
King takes f7 Queen takes d5 and Queen
takes Chifa Queen takes c5 not bad but
unfortunately his opponent had it and
even stronger response here yes f5
where's my F pawn
Knight f5 you mean here from Knight f5 I
mean we're in 1844 where do you think
the Kings going up the board no question
Kings gonna have four Kings gonna G four
Kings going somewhere up the board
probably I would play let's say King F
four so I don't lose my queen I mean
this is not something I want to allow
King F for and then we would of course
after Bishop III check play King at five
I mean the only way is up but after this
we finally get to bring our King maybe
back into civilization and who knows
maybe why it's actually better which is
kind of insane
so black actually had this idea I'm
gonna play Knight takes d5 Knight f7
he's one step ahead of him he wasn't
gonna let him show off with Knight f7 he
was gonna show off by castling so it's
like one upping you know you bid 500 I
bid 600 and simple castling a legal
castle it is legal to castle when your
rook is attacked as long as these
squares in the middle aren't covered and
your King's not in check now if your
King is attacked you can't castle but if
your rook is attacked you can probably
1844 was the first time that they
realized that
so after castling I mean it would take a
lot of willpower not to capture the
Queen here maybe that should have been
what happened but he didn't he didn't
capture the Queen now let's imagine they
played a different move let's say Queen
takes Knight let's say black plays rook
takes the knight here and again if I
play queen takes Bishop because I feel
like you know I have to if I don't take
it actually the material is close to
even let's say you take it well the
issue is that I'm going to play like
Queen g5 King age 3 and d6 and I'm just
gonna be delivering a checkmate here
because your King has nowhere to go
it's funny White's King was actually
safer when it was up on f5 so you should
probably have reconsidered so there's
not really a way to bail out of this
unfortunately when you see your opponent
Mason make some crazy move like this you
kind of have to indulge okay 98 I mean
it's hard to say no Bishop f2 this is
really the idea of castling and bringing
that rope to the F file is he support
the move Bishop f2 and again you force
the King to the side of the board and
black is going to continue let's say
King h3 we see them of d6 check why
didn't white play g4 here he didn't but
why didn't you
g4 actually blocks the check seems to
kind of handle that diagonal pawn to g4
metaphor is actually me that's a little
embarrassing an ITIN the bishop just
check meaning and king it's an ugly mate
well the only square I have is g4 but
let's not forget the bishop checking
from c8 doesn't even allow me to use
that square for the King so you know if
I put my Queen on g4 what would do we
play because I remember as white you're
almost up so much material metaphor
still mate though that's embarrassing
you know you got the the the king is
still in trouble you're getting into a
street fight the woman steps in the
middle try to break things up but you're
still getting punched over top just get
in the overhand right treatment from the
Black Knight here I mean it's ridiculous
she can't help you ecigs the only move
on the board really as we just looked at
white was getting checkmated by force in
every line so ii six and actually it's
kind of lucky that white even has this
move because that we are night on d8
which you never see a knight that deep
in enemy territory is actually
supporting the pawn so this is actually
maybe not so simple because remember you
give me one move what am i gonna do i'm
gonna play probably pawn here it's gonna
stop your knight from going to have four
and it's gonna facilitate my king taking
a step back into safety so again
everything has to be with tempo because
we can't ever give white that one move
that break that respite where he's gonna
get that King back to g2 and into safety
so Knight f4 check it's not checkmate
right we have the g4 square because of
this pawn on e6 taking away the bishop
so King g4 I mean it's the only move can
make it nice and quick Knight takes c6
and black is saying well okay now I've
taken your pawn this bishops gonna get
active again the only thing I can do is
say at least I'm gonna take your knight
so that there's no more of those Knight
f4 checkmates that kept happening to us
so Knight takes c6 Bishop takes and now
we have to do a little bit counting like
how many squares this white actually
have that
aren't completely losing I mean we've
got the rook here let's not forget
covering those we've got the bishop here
we've got this bishop here I mean I go
up the board don't have much of a choice
so the thing is it doesn't really matter
which square you go to because black is
going to have similar response so after
King up black is gonna check you and it
wouldn't have mattered if you went to h5
or 2g fund would have been the same
check would have been the same result
and again if we look at how many squares
are actually available here it's very
simple
King g4 h5 check always with checks King
h3 and now very nice it's just checkmate
that's a double check and it's me and
there's no where the King can move
because actually every piece near the
King is playing some sort of roll Bishop
on f2 is participating the bishop on e6
and the rook f3 combined for that
checkmate and the pawn on h5 let's not
forget was instrumental in even bringing
the King to this mating net the pawns on
g2 and h2 those are what we like to call
double agents working for us from the
inside out that's right we stationed
them there back in Nam and they've been
there ever since so they're doing a
great service to this game and this was
not the Petrov and I think it's probably
pretty clear that it was developed after
this game otherwise he might have used
it or probably he played this game and
said well I'm never playing that opening
again let's invent one I'll just call it
the Petrov because the this would
naturally leave a very bit poor taste in
your mouth doesn't feel feel good for
for white here so the thing is you know
he had to change his name after this
Alexander Hoffman had to change his name
too
Seymour Hoffman so that's where you know
him today he's been alive ever since but
what happened here White's King went for
another stroll but again it's almost
like you can't fault white because black
made this sort of insane move he Castle
you just can't expect stuff like this
and then you're you're you're all in at
this when you have to take the Queen
there's no other way
and with that was the same thing that
happened in the last example and the
first game we looked at is that none of
these games what was you know white sort
of willingly going out putting his King
in the open although you know I would
have to bring it back here and say maybe
King f1 and hindsight but Knight h6 by
who Knight h6 here sure you could play
Knight h6 let's say I take the issue for
me is I mean we'd love to set up you
know are sort of brilliant like kind of
check me where we get our Bishop in but
I mean unfortunately there can only
really be one brilliant mind per game
and I think early on white sort of
claimed that rule so black had to go
into submission and just you know white
was gonna be the mastermind with Knight
f7 black one up tomb by castling I mean
it's hard to one-up that move it's hard
to win up to castling maybe he should
have played it like I said with these
with these positions when you throw the
engine on it'll make everyone in this
game look really really poor right
nobody looks good when the engines on
it's kind of like at 3:00 a.m. when I
kick you out of the club they turn those
lights on nobody looks good
nobody looks good
so this was once again some sort of
insane game where White's King goes for
a stroll hasn't been white and every one
of these games but the concept of a king
being so brave and in a lot of these
cases had they played a little better
maybe the King would have even survived
and maybe it was actually even good out
there so it's not to say that these
games were completely one-sided that's
the way they felt but again if you
analyze these you'll be able to deduce
all there's so many ways that both sides
could have played better but again I
mean this is just what this sort of 18th
19th century games were we're all about
is these very fun games which are
exhilarating to play no matter which
color you had because how interesting
they were and we don't really see games
like that anymore in fact I can only
name a few off the top of my head but
when you do see them nowadays it's like
you're finding a gem like from the past
or something it's amazing it's like wow
the fact that your opponent who's so
well versed in theory and calculation or
maybe he's a grandmaster couldn't
foresee what you were gonna do because
back in the day it didn't look like
people put up a lot of resistance it's
like ok I'll just move my king out here
I hope I don't get made it nowadays I
think not only do you want to play the
best moves but you also don't ever want
to be on the receiving end of one of the
most brilliant games in history and
there's been a few of them I can name a
few like ding Lee ran and Yee have
played some very spectacular games where
they've sacrificed a number and a number
of pieces but you know back back in a
day I think I can still still appreciate
a lot of these a lot of these positions
a lot of these games which like I said
just look really fun to play no matter
which color you had and it's really
refreshing to sort of look back and see
the style back then which was totally
different because the whole chess
climate was was also different and now
things have changed more theoretical
bles fun depends with what's fun for you
but sacrificing is fun and can
definitely sacrifice less now because
everyone everyone has a computer that's
able to back them up but I thought these
these couple games here were pretty
exciting obviously the theme was King
walks today
but I also wanted to focus on some
players who most people have probably
never heard of and you know there were a
lot of really interesting games from the
Romantic era of chess and I thought
these guys definitely did their part in
contributing one of the first games you
looked at was this insane draw and then
from then we just checked out exactly
how to put away a king that goes for a
jog a little too far from home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you